completa el cuadrado en la ecuación
general cuadrática a x cuadrada más bx
más c igual a 0 y bueno ni te imaginas a
dónde vamos a llegar lo primero que voy
a hacer es es que menos me gusta tener
el término a x cuadrada
prefiero tener solamente hay que es
cuadrada y así es mucho más fácil
trabajarlo a mi parecer por lo tanto lo
que voy a hacer es quitar esta a que
está multiplicando el que es cuadrada
dividiendo todo entre a todo entre am
todo entre am todo entre am y bueno a
entre a se van y me queda simple y
sencillamente x cuadrada esto es 1 x x
cuadrada o sea x cuadrado más b entre a
por x + c / am y lo voy a poner un poco
más espaciado porque lo que quiero es
completar el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto más se entre am y después de
aunque esto es igual a cero entre am
pero cero entre lo que sea es cero muy
bien una expresión que me parece mucho
más amigable porque con esta expresión
voy a completar el binomio cuadrado
perfecto y recuerda que para completar
el binomio cuadrado perfecto me fijo
siempre en el coeficiente que está al
lado de la equis que en este caso es
/ a y bueno esto es lo mismo que 2 por b
entre 2 2 con el 2 se cancela y me
quedaría b entre a y esto lo pongo así
porque recuerda que al coeficiente que
está al lado de la x siempre hay que
dividirlo entre 2 para encontrar así mi
segundo término en este caso en mi
segundo término es b entre 2 y si yo
pongo el cuadrado de b entre 2 a pues es
b entre 2 am elevado todo al cuadrado
para no confundirnos y bueno yo estoy
agregando aquí p entre 2 a elevado al
cuadrado de la nada si lo estoy
agregando de la nada recuerda que
también lo tengo que quitar de la nada
por lo tanto voy a restarle b entre 2 a
al cuadrado si lo sumo y lo resto al
final es 0 y entonces realmente es como
si no estuviera haciendo nada y bueno lo
que quiero que te des cuenta es que
estos tres primeros términos es un
trinomio al cuadrado perfecto porque
tengo el cuadrado del primero más dos
veces el primero por el segundo más el
cuadrado del segundo y yo sé que tal vez
visto una forma general es un poco
confuso y no quiero que te confundas con
tantas veces c etcétera y bueno para que
sea mucho más fácil voy a escribir aquí
la fórmula del binomio al cuadrado
perfecto pero ten cuidado
vamos a mezclar estas emisiones con abc
m n elevado al cuadrado es lo mismo que
m cuadrada más dos veces el primero por
el segundo 2 mn más en el cuadrado que
es justo lo que tenemos aquí si te das
cuenta tenemos un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto y por lo tanto ya sé que en ese
segundo término el segundo término se ve
entre 2
y entonces lo puedo escribir de la forma
m
n elevado al cuadrado fíjate bien aquí
tengo dos veces el primero por el
segundo y dos cuadrados el cuadrado de
xy el cuadrado debe entre dos por lo
tanto esto de aquí lo puedo escribir de
la siguiente manera como todo esto de
rojo es un trinomio cuadrado perfecto lo
voy a factorizar y en que los vea
factorizar en x más de entre 2 am al
cuadrado date cuenta que esto lo mismo
que lo que está de rojo aquí arriba y
después tengo que hacer esta operación
de aquí pero lo primero que voy a hacer
es elevar el b entre 2 al cuadrado
entonces me queda menos y me quedaría b
cuadrada hay que poner el cuadrado de
ambos el cuadrado del de arriba y el
cuadrado desde abajo entonces me va a
quedar b cuadrada
entre 2 al cuadrado que es 4 a cuadrada
ya esto le tengo que sumar se entre a y
sería más cuando ya sacar de una vez el
factor común pero primero lo voy a poner
como central para que no te confundas y
ahorita voy a sacar el denominador común
para poder sumar estas dos expresiones
que tengo aquí ahora date cuenta que lo
que le falta al a aparecer 4a cuadrada
es multiplicar por 4 a por lo tanto voy
a multiplicar por 4 a tanto arriba como
abajo esta expresión me va a quedar 4
hace entre 4 cuadrada lo que me va a dar
un denominador común y entonces estos
dos suman 2 se van a poder reducir se
van a poder reducir porque tengo una
suma de quebrados y esto va a ser igual
a cero entonces dejen de escribirlo aquí
abajo me queda x + b entre 2 am todo
esto elevado al cuadrado y después tengo
como denominador común 4 a cuadrada por
lo tanto ya puedo sumar estas dos
expresiones ya arriba me quedaría 4 hace
positivo y menos de cuadrada entonces
voy a poner aquí menos b cuadrada más 4
ac y todo esto está dividido entre 4 al
cuadrado y esto es igual
bueno pero la idea tras la que voy es
despejar a x o al menos dejar el término
x menos b entre 2 a al cuadrado lo más
solo que se pueda de algún lado de la
ecuación por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer
es pasar todo este término del otro lado
por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es
cambiar de signo a los términos que
están arriba de este quebrado pero
déjame hacerlo con otro color voy a
tomar el color azul y bueno entonces le
voy a cambiar el signo a los sumandos
que están aquí arriba para que se
cancelen y entonces los pueda pasar del
otro lado no va a quedar be cuadrada
menos 4 a cm entre 4 a cuadrada y del
otro lado tengo que hacer lo mismo si
estoy sumando de un lado también lo
tengo que hacer del otro lado para que
la igualdad se mantenga entonces ahora
sí que me va a quedar de sumar esto y
sumar esto del otro lado bueno yo tengo
que esto de amarillo y esto de azul se
va a cancelar porque menos de cuadrada
más de cuadradas evans menos 4 hace más
4 acs van y sirve sencillamente me
quedaría que todo esto se va entonces me
queda de la búsqueda de la ecuación x +
b entre 2
a todo esto elevado al cuadrado esto ya
se fue y del lado derecho de mi ecuación
a quien me va a quedar esto
igual de cuadrada a menos espera espera
mejor déjeme ponerlo con color azul y
así no nos vamos a confundir mientras
que del lado derecho me va a quedar de
cuadrada menos 4 hace entre 4 a cuadrada
y bueno si lo que queremos resolver para
x entonces lo que voy a hacer es sacar
raíz cuadrada de ambos lados la ecuación
y que me va a quedar recuerda que tras
lo que voy es despejar a x por lo tanto
voy a sacar raíz cuadrada de ambos lados
de la ecuación y recuerda que cuando yo
sea x raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada
toma dos raíces tanto una raíz positiva
como una raíz negativa por lo tanto
cuando yo aplico la raíz cuadrada me va
a quedar más menos la raíz cuadrada de a
lo que se le aplique entonces voy a
poner aquí mi raíz cuadrada y voy a
poner del otro lado mi raíz cuadrada
aquí no le voy a poner más menos aquí sí
le voy a poner más menos por la
siguiente razón que les voy a explicar
si yo le pusiera más menos a ambos lados
de la ecuación entonces pasaría lo
siguiente me estaría tomando más
posibilidades de las que debería es
decir al final cuando yo pase el más
menos del otro lado va a pasar como
menos más y cuando multiplique al más
al final me va a dar un signo positivo y
un signo negativo por lo tanto para
ahorrarnos todos estos tickets solo le
ponemos más menos del lado derecho de la
ecuación y bueno la raíz con el cuadrado
son operaciones inversas por lo tanto se
cancelan y del lado derecho solamente me
queda x + b entre 2 am más ve entre 2 am
aquí desaparece la raíz cuadrada y el
cuadrado y del otro lado me queda más
menos la raíz cuadrada de todo esto que
está aquí sin embargo quiero que veas
que cuando yo saco la raíz cuadrada de
una fracción esto es lo mismo que sacar
la raíz cuadrada del denominador y a su
vez sacar la raíz cuadrada del numerador
es decir que cuando tenemos la raíz
cuadrada de una fracción podemos separar
la raíz y lo genial de todo esto es que
poco a poco vamos moldeando la fórmula
general de cuestiones de segundo grado
pero bueno aquí arriba en el numerador
tenemos una resta y recuerda que cuando
yo tengo una resta o una diferencia no
puedo sacar la raíz cuadrada de cada uno
de los términos por lo tanto voy a poner
arriba la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada
menos 4 ac y fíjate que puse aquí más
menos para no pelearme con los signos a
las
acción la verdad no importa porque
siempre tenemos una raíz positiva y una
raíz negativa solamente dos
posibilidades obtener un número negativo
o tener un número positivo y bueno esto
entre dos a la raíz cuadrada de cuatro
al cuadrado es 2 am y ahora a
continuación lo que voy a hacer es
restarle a ambos lados de la ecuación
menos b entre 2 a y b entre 2 a menos b
entre 2 aceba y del lado izquierdo ya
por fin me queda solamente x del lado
derecho me queda menos b entre 2 a más
menos la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada
menos 4 hace todo esto también dividido
entre 2 a estos dos quebrados ya tienen
un denominador común y el denominador
común es 2a por lo tanto me queda menos
b más menos la raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada menos 4 hace entre 2 am y si te
das cuenta aquí tenemos dos raíces una
positiva y una negativa si suponemos que
la raíz cuadrada existe entonces me voy
a tomar la raíz positiva y después no
voy a tomar la raíz negativa y esto me
va a dar dos soluciones cosa que es
congruente con todo lo que hemos visto
hasta ahorita y si te das cuenta esta
fórmula que tengo aquí es la fórmula que
he aprendido
a veces partimos de una ecuación a equis
cuadrada más bx más e igual a cero a
ésta se le conoce como la ecuación
general de segundo grado y llegamos a la
solución menos b más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4 ac entre
2 a hasta parece poema y toda esta
solución es una solución muy importante
pues a esta solución se le conoce como
la fórmula cuadrática o en su dado caso
como la solución general de las
ecuaciones de segundo grado y esta es
una de las fórmulas más importantes y
que más salen en todo el mundo de las
matemáticas y si te das cuenta la
obtuvimos simple y sencillamente
completando el cuadrado y aunque no soy
muy fanático de que se memoriza en las
cosas creo que te podría ser muy útil en
la vida si lo haces